donc ça c'est ma blouse elle est
raccrochée vous m'empêchez de travailler
vous m'empêcher d'aller voir mes
patients vous me parlez d'éthique vous
avez envoyé les positifs au lit du
malade alors que nous négatifs
chez moi les tiques en fait c'est de
respecter le consentement du patient
parce que me dites pas qu'il y a pas
d'effet un désir à Monsieur Véran on est
à 190 000 vous êtes vacciné contre
l'hépatite B mais monsieur
au bout du raisonnement pour vous il
fait quoi ce vaccin vous vous ne savez
pas ce qui va faire dans la notice il
est noté et vous êtes médecin vous
devriez le savoir vous devriez lire les
notices
il est marqué qu'ils sont en étude
jusque quand décembre 2023 étude
clinique chez moi cette période monsieur
vous ne faites pas confiance au médecin
avec lesquels vous travaillez mais vous
voyez que vous fasse confiance